Olha só, você sabia que uma simples
rachadura no dente pode te levar paraa
UTI? Pois é, parece exagero, mas veja só
o que aconteceu com esse britânico de 61
anos. O Graham estava arrumando o carro
para viajar quando a esposa notou que o
rosto dele estava caído de um lado. Dor
de cabeça intensa, confusão mental,
acharam que era AVC, mas não. Era um
abesso cerebral de 3 cm. E sabe de onde
veio? De um dente trincado que ele nem
sabia que estava infectado. Zero dor,
zero inchaço na boca, nada.
Então, quando você tem uma rachadura no
dente, mesmo pequenininha, é como deixar
uma porta aberta pros microrganismos.
Essas bactérias entram na corrente
sanguínea e podem viajar direto pro
cérebro. O pior é que muitas vezes não
dá sinal nenhum na boca. O primeiro
sintoma já pode ser neurológico, dor de
cabeça forte, febre e até convulsão.
Então fica a dica. Notou uma rachadura
no dente mesmo sem dor, vai pro
dentista. Prevenção simples que pode
literalmente salvar vidas. M.